hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
video zum mittag kam mir eigentlich
schon video und ich hatte ja nicht nur
ein video normalerweise hoch allerdings
wollte ich in diesem video jetzt einfach
mal auf das video heute mittag so ein
bisschen eingehen weil das jedoch so ein
paar fragen aufgeworfen hat das video
was ich heute mittag hochgeladen habe
war ein werbevideo in kooperation mit
dem kinofilm nerv bei dem es darum geht
dass man challenges bekommt und dem
reifen welt liegen müssen die challenges
werden halt von challenge zu challenge
immer schwerer aber ich mit max ein team
und andere youtuber die das unter
anderem auch gemacht haben sind
beispielsweise kelly und mal wanne und
kay streak und knapp jedes team hat
quasi drei videos wieder kampagne
gemacht und das waren beispielsweise bei
kelly dass sie sich als die kutsche
verkleiden musste und durch berlin
laufen musste rees und gravy mussten
plötzlich in der berliner innenstadt
einfach los tanzen und im ersten video
von maximal musste ich nicht als katze
begleiten im zweiten video mussten wir
mit handschellen einen tag durch köln
auf und im dritten video ist heute
mittag hochgeladen was wir da machen
mussten übrigens ist das hier nicht
irgendwie auch noch ein bezahltes
product placement oder werbevideo oder
sponsored oder so dass es einfach nur
weil ich das gerne hochladen wollte und
was klarstellen wollte ich zeige euch
erstmal das intro von dem video was ich
heute mittag hochgeladen habe will
konditioniert ein spiel die wahrheit
oder pflicht nur ohne die wahrheit ist
in einer gewissen form genau das weiß
ich schon gesagt habe zwar mal bekommen
die challenge und wenn man die challenge
meistert kriegt man geld und dann eine
härtere chalip sage ich mal wir haben
natürlich nicht wirklich das geld
bekommen das waren nur um das ganze kurz
darzustellen hübschen channels bekommen
begebt euch auf hotel der genau wir
haben quasi die challenge bekommen als
allererstes dass wir uns auf das dach
unseres hoteles beginnen soll und wir
dachten uns erstmal okay mit naughty dog
wir sind halt ich's treppenhaus nach
ganz oben gegangen das war dann
irgendwie 70 meter höhe und dann habe
ich halt das hier gesagt ich weiß nicht
habe nicht nur eine höhe nannte mich
bitte respektvoll höre ich habe
höhenangst
mir wird es einmal gesagt luca du hast
keine höhenangst aber ich habe
höhenangst ich meine ich fliege relativ
häufig und ich war auch schon in new
york auf dem
world one world trade center war es ja
auch irgendwie was ich über 500 meter
hoch ist und da hatte ich auch keine
angst also ich konnte einfach unter
gucken und fand das chill ich habe aber
ein respekt vor der höhe wenn ich selber
irgendwas mit der höhe zu tun habe und
quasi die kontrolle über mein körper
nicht mehr selbst habe sondern die
kontrolle an einem fallschirm hängend
oder an einem bungee-seil oder einem
seil an dem ich mich festhalten will auf
jeden fall auf diesem hotel angekommen
und wurden dann in solche anzüge
geklemmt und dann haben wir die aufgabe
bekommen dass wir an der wand so einfach
herunter laufen und nicht dass wir so im
rücken sind und dann in wien nach oben
gucken das handy safe gemacht dass
werden die stimmen gewesen aber man
musste nach unten
ich hasse 11 die kontrolle über sein
leben an einem seil zu überlassen das
ganze war von jochen schweizer und ich
weiß wann kann in allen vertrauen und da
ist auch noch nie wirklich was passiert
und ich mache ja auch falsche spiel
machen dass er alles und mega lang man
ist total gesichert und soll beim nein
ich hasse es ja auch zu fliegen oder
bahn zu fahren oder irgendwas wenn ich
nicht auto fahren wenn ich selber weiß
okay wenn was passiert habe ich die
kontrolle und ich kann alles hier machen
ich bin einfach so ein kontrollfreak was
sowas angeht wenn es wirklich um die
gesundheit geht und dann habe ich sie
halt gefragt weil ich ja unbedingt
machen wollte ob sie vielleicht
irgendwelche tipps für mich hat was
nicht so krass
du kannst und tipp ist wenn du angst
hast nicht runter schaut nicht und was
habe ich fünf sekunden später getan oh
mein gott habe ich direkt nach unten
geguckt habe ich hab es mir halt selber
schwer gemacht und ich hatte dafür total
war das kann wachstums kann die
produktion sollte bezeugen ich konnte
wirklich die mussten wir das alles
dreimal erklärt weil ich nicht mehr
richtig zuhören können ich habe wirklich
ganz auf dem boden gelockert migranten
ediger du machst was nicht und er nahm
ich ein jo-jo und kate zu eigen die
höhenlagen ich probiere es einfach mal
so ich stell mich von meiner angst und
mein erster versuch sei halt so aus ich
hab mir das linke durch die rückhand
allerdings ich bei nach links ab 10 uhr
auf dem linken weniger und da haben sich
wirklich sehr viele leute gefragt luca
hast du verlangst du was komplett gerade
wisst ihr es ist nicht so dass man
irgendwie so ein seil bekommt was so um
einen rum geht und dann so zwischen den
beiden her sondern kriegten sein was
rechts von einem ist und ich hatte das
einheit rechts und der mensch denkt okay
ich weiter vorne ich halte mich an dem
nächsten gegenstand fest das war halt
dieses teil bei mir und damit das ganze
system wird muss man das seil so ein
bisschen lockerer lassen und das seit
weil sie durch bleiben lassen das kann
max aufgezogen und dann geht man quasi
immer weiter nach oben und lässt sich
quasi ab sein ich habe das ganze
allerdings irgendwie nicht richtig
geschnallt und hatte auch übelste angst
davor dass sein loszulassen habe mir
gedacht okay ich halte das sei die ganze
zeit fest dass ich weiß ich kann jetzt
sogar nicht mehr reden sie hat sich halt
einfach weiß okay ich bin said wenn ich
falle und hat das sei dann allianz
dorffest kann dadurch dass ich so lange
festgehalten habe bin ich irgendwie nach
links gegangen weil das seil der rechts
und wieder mit dem rechten fuß ein
bisschen hatte angst dass bei links weil
die kante das ist dann so link ach das
war auf jeden fall nicht so gut wie ich
das gemeistert habe dann hab ich halt
gedacht okay ich machen zweiten versuch
an und ich versuche diesmal nicht nach
links zu gehen als ich dich mir
allerdings ich gehe es geht nicht
ja ich bin schon wieder einiges gegangen
und ich schwöre euch ich habe da nicht
verarscht es war wirklich so ich stand
immer weiter sondern links und wie zwar
nicht so aus vielleicht hab ich mir
eingebildet und ich stand in dieser
schräge weg ich mir das vorstelle ich
kann ehrlich so an der kante sondern ich
stand ja wirklich schon so weit nach
vorne das heißt in die sicherung
gerissen der welt halt einfach runter
geklappt wie stand in dieser position
zweimal und das erste mal irgendwie
locker fünf sekunden das zweite mal
locker irgendwie zehn sekunden aber dann
habe ich für mich selbst gesagt ich kann
das nicht ich hab einfach angst kriegt
das nicht hin ich herzlich besiegen mir
scheiß egal was die leute jetzt denke
ich will einfach nicht darunter gehen
und in ohnmacht fallen und denkt oh gott
nein macht das jetzt nur weil es mir
selbst beweisen würde den leuten und
leider umgehen egal ich hätte das
einfach nur gemacht weil ich dachte okay
das ist cool das macht spaß aber
er hat keinen spaß gemacht also ich hab
es ja auch nicht wirklich gemacht jeder
der dort oben stand auch max auch die
vom produktionsteam haben alle gesandte
schwierigste daran ist dieser schritt
über die klippe weil es nicht so ist wie
beispielsweise beim fallschirmsprung des
du mit nem typen das ist kannst die
augen zu machen fällt einfach raus und
dann ist es gar nicht vorbei und da ist
halt so dass man selber das in der hand
hat und sagen kann okay ich gehe nach
vorne gott nein ich bis heute auf sich
allein gestellt und muss das selber
hinkriegen diesen schritt in die ich
nicht ich doch ihr wisst was ich meine
und das schwierigste habe ich war sie
zweimal gemacht also diesen schritt über
diese kante in die schräge zweimal mache
warum zwei mal nicht die eier gehabt
nach unten zu laufen ich weiß nicht
nennen wie ruhig die pussy aber so sah
das seien oft auch hier nach einblendung
wie es abgebrochen habe dann
supercool dass die produktion auch so
traurige musik kinder gepackt hat aber
naja ich habe es auf jeden fall nicht
hingekriegt und wollte euch nur kurz
sagen woran das bei mir lagen also ich
glaube es lag nicht mehr so krass an der
höhenangst oder meinen respekt vor der
höhe sondern einfach daran dass ich das
sei die ganze zeit so festgehalten habe
dem system nicht vertraut habe und
deswegen halt nicht vorwärts kam nach
links geknallt bin und irgendwie keine
ahnung ich wollte euch das nur sagen wie
es für mich waren ich hatte todesangst
deswegen habe ich dann abgebrochen und
nicht gegen das unternehmen mit dem ihr
das macht habe aber es gibt ja leute die
das zwiebel feiern an seiner wand runter
zu laufen
wir hätten locker auch überhaupt keinen
spaß gemacht weil ich bin ich hab jetzt
wird sie es auch nicht ein dass leute
gerne klettern oder so aber jeder hat
eine leidenschaft und das ist gut so
aber meine leidenschaft ist höhe und
klettern und bungee jumping und
fallschirmspringen auf jeden fall nicht
ich wollte da auf jeden fall ist nur mal
kurz drüber reden weil ich nicht
irgendwie dazu gefühlt habe euch dazu
meine meinung mitzuteilen wie das ganze
gemacht habe habe ich auch noch bei
facebook live stream gemacht und hab das
doch schon erläutert warum ich mich dazu
entschlossen habe das doch nicht zu
machen aber ich wollte das auch noch mal
die auf youtube euch sagen so wenn euch
dieses video gefallen hat und euch das
gefällt dass ich euch auch so
hintergründe von dem welchen reisen von
mir oder warum ich bestimmt aktion
gemacht haben oder einfach so dass ich
zu einem normalen video auf einem kanal
noch ein zweites video mache was einfach
hier so ein reaktions video quasi ist
oder seinem real talk video wenn euch
das gefällt es mir gern mit einem like
und ihr könnt jetzt hier oben meinen
kanal abonnieren und hier findet ihr
noch mal das video von heute mittag
eingeblendet wie gesagt dieses video
hier gerade überhaupt nicht bezahlt oder
so es war einfach nur ich hab mir selber
gedacht wird sagen und wenn ihr sehen
wollt wie es halt ab liegt soll dass das
video an dem kanal abonnieren und wir
sehen uns dann wenn anders